I don't know
about aliens,
but I know that you are gorgeous.
Am I going to get fired
if I turn this place?
That's that's too much flirting with a.
Is it
a future
or an even more embarrassing way
to chat with someone new?
We tried out an app called Keys A.I.
to test out if A.I.
has game.
So to test Keys A.I..
Amanda and I.
I'm in L.A.. She's in New York.
We haven't met, but we matched
And I'm going to be using Keys A.I.
to see how much it holds up,
how much it actually might be useful.
That's right.
All right,
so I've got hands open,
and I'm just going to start
with an breaker.
Okay. So it gives me some options.
Quirky. Let's write. Quirky.
Quirky. Looks good.
Okay, so right click. I
You look like the kind of person
who would make a point about the word
nugget. Nugget, nugget.
No pressure.
I can't think of one.
Okay, she's responding.
What kind of pun
could you make up with that word?
I'm coming up blank.
All right,
so it has this auto response feature,
so I'm going to try that.
Let's see if
I can can come up with a good one.
Whoa.
Three options.
I'm trying to picture you
without clothes on.
I'm going to to get you up
I could tell you, but it would be
to new beauty person to.
Is that some kind of the fresh
All right, get your any of those.
Now, I'm starting to think
that he's
not that witty
because he should have
already thought of what fun
he could have made with that word.
Before sending me
this message
should have been really quick with it.
I'm losing interest.
I thought you would have
had something on deck, John.
I'm a little disappointed TV age.
Well, I'm like,
man, he's got high
standards here, as she should.
She should last about five points on the
on the win there.
I'm a little disappointed too.
You have to give me a second.
I'm still reeling from your beauty,
Amanda. Okay, these are too intense.
All right. I was going to pivot.
She just ask me your question.
What's your favorite comedy movie?
That's a good question.
And I think that's a good question.
Throw at the
I mean,
I think everyone
should have an answer to that.
But, you know, curious what a
curious one. And his
favorite comedy movie is
I'm a sucker for anything with water.
I hate okay.
I do like Super Bowl.
I'm as I'm going to write this one.
This is this is from me, not the air.
I'm sneaking this one at
I'll make love in this club.
Okay.
That's the funniest thing that he said.
Like that kind of like
one some points back
from like the earlier
hey, how's it going down, right?
It didn't even seem
like you looked at my profile.
I feel like you just could have, like,
been talking to anybody,
and I honestly would have, like,
just put my phone down,
like, after, like,
the sixth thing that it's said to me,
it didn't really ask them any questions
about yourself.
Maybe that's not really in the air.
I built it in there.
Do you think that this could ever
be used? Practically,
yes, but not in its current form.
I think it has potential.
I think it does.
It's got little work to do.